his third claim is that the elongated
skulls do not have foran ovali there are
things called foran ovali I believe
they're called which are up and inside
here in the skull that is where nerve
and blood flow comes out to feed the
face and that gives us our facial
expressions they seem to be absent in
the paracas elongated skulls the fan o
valy are these little holes on the
bottom of the skull that are colored in
green right here if I look at my
elongated skull if I flip it over you
can see quite clearly that actually
right there you have in fact the foro
valley and if you go and you look at the
actual picture that he has on his
website of his own skulls from his
Museum the ones that he says don't have
them they very clearly do have them
they're right there Brian's thirdd claim
is also false you can click the little
play button overlaid here or find a link
in the video description for my full
review